près d'un mois après sa sortie le film
Barbie a dépassé le milliard de dollars
au box-office mondial devenant le plus
gros succès cinématographique de l'été
mais au-delà du succès commercial cette
comédie hollywoodienne qui met en scène
l'emblématique poupée Mattel aux côtés
de son petit ami Ken a suscité la
controverse aux quatre coins du monde
tourra tour à cuisiner de porter
atteintes à la morale publique de
promouvoir l'homosexualité ou
d'introduire des idées étrangères le
film de Greta garbig a été censuré et
même interdit dans plusieurs pays c'est
notamment en Moyen-Orient que le film
Barbie a créé un certain malaise au même
titre que d'autres productions
hollywoodiennes accusées de propagande
LGBT la diffusion des films Barbie et
talk to me a été interdite annonçait le
10 août la fille soubaye président du
comité de l'ascenseur cinématographique
du Koweït avant de prendre leur décision
les autorités de cette monarchie
conservatrice avait demandé la
suppression de certaines scènes obscènes
encourageant des comportements
inacceptables à indiquer le responsable
le ministre des médias du Koweït tient
en effet à interdire tout ce qui porte
atteinte à la morale publique à l'ordre
public et aux traditions par
l'introduction d'idées étrangères au
sein de société la veille le ministre
libanais de la culture Mohamad muhtaga à
lui aussi demandé l'interdiction de
Barbie pour des raisons similaires il
soutient que le film qui devait être
projeté au Liban à partir du 31 août va
à l'encontre des valeurs morales et
religieuses au Liban barbie fait la
promotion de l'homosexualité et du
changement de sexe soutient le rejet de
la tutelle du père mine et tournant
ridicule le rôle de la mer et remettent
en question la nécessité du mariage et
de la formation d'une famille cette
résistance touche l'ensemble du monde
musulman ainsi la province pakistanaise
du Panjab avait repoussé la sortie du
film jugeant son contenu choquant tandis
que l'Algérie la retiré discrètement des
salles de cinéma plus de deux semaines
après sa sortie selon le site
d'information TSA le ministre algérien
de la culture mais notamment en cause
des scènes destinées à un public adulte
en contradiction avec les valeurs
traditionnelles du pays dans le golf
deux exceptions notables toutefois
l'Arabie Saoudite ou le blockbuster fait
sale comble dans tous les cinémas du
pays et les Émirats arabes unis ou le
Conseil national des médias a fini par
valider la projection du film après un
certain délai ces deux pays avaient
pourtant eux aussi interdit des films
contenant des références LGBT car s'il
ne contient ni baiser ni scène de sexe
explicite représentait la diversité des
genres et l'un des objectifs affichés de
la comédie Barbie c'est ce qui
expliquait début juillet la réalisatrice
Greta garrigue au magazine OUT mais
souvent des portes dans l'univers de
Barbie nous pouvions pas raconter cette
histoire sans y intégrer la communauté
LGBT que plus le choix des acteurs n'est
pas anodin la Barbie docteur est
interprétée par la comédienne transgenre
Harry Neff tandis que Ken stéréotypé
allait être de l'acteur gay Scott Evan
en France la comédie américaine a passé
ce week-end la barre des 4 millions
d'entrées devenant le troisième plus
gros succès de l'année